we certainly are cutting it close for
sure
well families can now experience the
magic of the tradition
of the nutcracker up close the pandemic
put the las vegas production on hold but
well there's a new exhibit offering a
rare behind the scenes look
and hector mejia is live this morning
inside the discovery children's museum
to give us a look and give us the
details good morning hector i
love the nutcracker
isn't a great good morning sherry a lot
of the elements that bring the
nutcracker to life are here right behind
me we're talking about
set props we're talking about set pieces
costumes
wings wings wigs a lot of other things
and joining us live we have melissa
kaiser here ceo at the discovery
children's museum
to talk to us you know how unique is
this of an opportunity
this is such a special opportunity
because normally all of these sets and
costumes are
on stage at the smith center at this
time of year so fortunately
through our long-standing partnership
with nevada ballet we've been able to
bring our
real sets and costumes here for the kids
to enjoy and the collection is
large and here we have a piece of that
this is just a portion this is what
could fit in our space safely with
social distancing for families
but um the collection is really quite
incredible
and there's a lot to see we have a lot
of items around here and this
uh it's a pretty large size of an area
that we have here where we can
get really close you know obviously we
can't touch anything but you can get
really close
that's right so normally from a distance
you can't see this detail
but here the kids can watch elements of
the scenes
and find the details up close in real
life and really see the magic of these
costumes
this is exciting let's talk about the
details it all opens tomorrow
and it's open until january 3rd so
there's only a short two-week window
that's right but given that there are
not as many experiences for families to
enjoy at the holidays we hope that this
brings a little joy
all right thank you very much so we'll
be here throughout the morning to show
you
uh all of what they have to offer here
and one more thing sherry
they have a costume set aside for me so
maybe
maybe not i'll put it on and maybe we'll
see which one of these i'll get to try
on
i'll have to stick around and i'll try
that on still ahead in half an hour
reporting live hector mejia 8 news now
there's a tease and don't go anywhere
people
thanks hector which one is he gonna put
on
i want to see hector in another which
one alex which one you gotta put on
well nate says nutcracker so yes that is
so exciting and
you know what i like i like i like the
mouse the giant mouse
that's the costume oh okay i'm hearing a
lot of
support for that in my ear from the
control room
not from the voices in my head all right